si dans notre monde moderne plus un
mariage ou de manifestation ne se fait
sans une sono et à coups de décibels
parfois exagérées et surdosé en basse
autrefois d'antan longtemps comme disent
les anciens à une époque où la fée
électricité n'alimentait pas tous les
foyers
l'essentiel des animations musicales se
faisait par le biais des orchestres en
cuir belgique en cuir c'est le loquace
que l'a fait dans ce moule grand pardon
que la fée morgane grands parents que
l'a fait mme marie beaucoup de gens à
l'époque
à l'époque cela commence danser avec l
orchestre cuivre nous sommes à saint
denis dans les locaux de la petite scène
de spectacle la fabrique c'est là que
nous avons rencontré jean-françois monde
la musique en cuivre à lui c'est une
grande histoire d'amour
un rêve de petit enfant alors cette
aventure là là commence très très
longtemps parce que moment été maquée
petit harry pop et chaque fois qu'ils en
aient amené dans une fête quand elle
avait alors qu'elle s'en suivre ma maman
télé samoela qui reprend mois après même
deux heures trois ans après que le
familier prêté devant lors qu'elles sont
cuites et ils veulent en cassant clivé
mois l'a mis dans ma tête que tfm jamie
choi des nôtres
après s'être lancée dans la musique
coachés par ses deux enfants françois
damiens et natacha eux mêmes musiciens
et après une tournée en métropole avec
l' orchestre tout ça jean-françois
décide de réaliser son rêve d'enfant
créer son propre orchestre festival
d'angoulême en entrant voilà ma vie de
trois dalons un droit d'allemands qui
connaissent les tours puis mal à crémone
en caisse il encaisse là commence comme
ça c'est un des rêves indirects le
saxophoniste réunit alors quelques
ballons et monte son propre groupe
les cuivres de l'est des dalons qui pour
certains la musique a pris une forme
thérapeutique
c'est un petit peu une thérapie par la
musique
c'est à dire moi trouve des gens me
donnent toujours quoi joue un corner on
emmène au dakota bordeaux vient jouer
avec nous le goût de la quitte le lit et
l'avait pointe roque médicaments de
l'america il est dit que que la musique
est si nous avons rencontré
jean-françois à la fabrique ce n'est pas
un hasard
ce jour-là son orchestre inaugure un
carrousel un autre rêve qui se réalise
aujourd'hui c'est encore un autre rêve
c'est vraiment un rêve depuis un certain
temps me dit tu es moyennant 48 malades
on la gagne pièces cette occasion cuivre
tout demoun i koné lankais sont créés
mais si je serais content mais ce
n'était pas rien dans ce 1 fabriqué qu'à
auxerre avec leurs casques donc elle
s'enfuit vima le public est quant à lui
ravi qu'il soit jeune ou moins jeune
impeccable génial super u savent rester
des enfants aux toiles en france c'est
magnifique c'est beau ça mon gamin il
les aura tous essayé je pense à cinq
arrières d'ofer enfin à plein de
couleurs d'ail pelées bironneau
marmaille on a même rencontré de jeunes
mariés venus pour l'occasion
les cuivres de l'est ont animé leur
soirée de mariage de nous emmener dans
un univers de longtemps quoi
l'ambiance est assurée jean françois et
ses acolytes ne sont pas peu fiers de
mouler la de money vient pour 10 à nos
demandes et nous les fiers de ça que
nous fait nous les vieux segal le stand
anthony veille pour tabac sur ka sat est
fait avant
six axes y trouvons nous dans le chemin
vieille garde viendra même si l'ambiance
avec nous à bientôt